تبنى عدد من القوى والشخصيات الوطنيه
والشبابيه في مصر وثيقتين منفصلتين تحت
اسم وثيقه العهد ووثيقه الاتفاق الوطني
تضمنت بنودا ستطرح على مرشحي الرئاسه
الذين سيخوضان جوله الاعاده منتصف الشهر
[موسيقى]
المقبل
يتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما مدى واقعيه الشروط التي تضعها
القوى السياسيه والشبابيه لدعم احد
المرشحين في مرحله الاعاده وماهي
الاستعدادات الى الطرفين للاستجابه الى
هذه الشروط والمطلوبات قبل انتخابات الدور
الثاني
في اطار تفاعلات ما قبل جوله الاعاده في
انتخابات الرئاسه المصريه بدات القوى
والتيارات السياسيه التي ابعدت مرشحيها
نتيجه الجوله الاولى ترتيب صفوفها لانقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه مما تسميه اهداف ومكتسبات
الثوره وذلك عبر طرح قائمه من المطالب
تشترط على اساسها دعم احد مرشحي الدوره
الثانيه من انتخابات الرئاسه محمد مرسي
مرشح حزب الحريه والعداله المنبثق عن
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين واحمد شفيق المرشح
المستقل واخر رئيس وزراء في عهد
مبارك ما افرزته الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لم يجعل كثيرا من
المصريين يتنفسون السعداء فالنتيجه غير
الحاسمه التي افضت اليها وضعتهم ووضعت
الكل من فائزين وخاسر امام خيارات محدوده
فالاخوان ومن خلال مرشحهم محمد مرسي ورغم
تصدرهم للنتائج
حاجه الى اصوات القوى الاخرى لمواجهه
المرشح احمد شفيق كما ان الاحزاب المدنيه
وانصار ما بات يعرف بمعسكر الطريق الثالث
ظهروا وكانهم في ورطه الاختيار بين
الدولتين الدينيه والعسكريه وبما ان
المرشحين الرئاسيين مرسي وشفيق خرجا من
الجوله الاولى في موقف ضعيف نسبيا فانهما
سرعا الى بث رسائل الطمنه ومحاوله استقطاب
المجموعات السياسيه ذات الوزن في معركه
الانتخابات هذه المجموعات التي ادركت قيمه
كتلتها التصويتيه عمدت من جهتها الى
امتحان المرشحين عبر محاوله الزامه ما
بشروطها قبل اكثر من اسبوعين من يوم
الانتخاب عدد من الاحزاب والشخصيات
السياسيه المصريه ارتات اصدار ما يمكن
وصفها بخريطه طريق لمن يسعى الى كرسي
الرئاسه هي عباره عن وثيقه سميت وثيقه
العهد الوطني وتتضمن هذه الوثيقه بنودا من
بينها تشكيل الجمعيه التي ستضع الدستور
الجديد للبلاد من اطياف الشعب المصري
المختلفه وتعيين نائبين للرئيس من
الشخصيات الوطنيه ذات القبول العام في مصر
وان تكون لنائب صلاحيات محدده معلنه مسبقا
ومؤثره في القرار السياسي لمؤسسه الرئاسه
وتنص الوثيقه ايضا على ضروره ان يعلن محمد
مرسي استقالته النهائيه من حزب الحريه
والعداله وجماعه الاخوان لضمان استقلاليه
مؤسسه الرئاسه وان تشكل حكومه ائتلافيه
موسعه تشمل الاقباط والمراه والشباب ويكون
رئيسها من خارج حزب الحريه والعداله وعبرت
الوثيقه ايضا عن المخاوف من انفراد حزب
الحريه والعداله بمقاليد الدوله وبما ان
هذه الوثيقه تحدثت عن تزايد فرص وصول من
قالت انه لا يؤمن بالثوره ولا باهداف الى
سده الحكم فقد بدا واضحا ان الشروط
المذكوره تستهدف المرشح الاخواني محمد
مرسي بالدرجه الاولى والذي يبدو ان عليه
ان يخرج برسائل وتطمينات هي في الواقع
اكثر بكثير مما ورد في مؤتمره الصحفي
الاخير ولمناقشة
رد رسمي لا بالرفض ولا بالقبول عن هذه
المقترحات يعني مؤكد اننا مشهد في حاجه
الى الاصطفاف الوطني
والعهد الملزم لكافه الاطراف والذي يدلل
على اننا بصدد حقيقه شراكه وطنيه في
المرحله القادمه لا يستحوذ فيها فصيل ولا
طيار ولا جماعه ولا حزب لكن انا اقف مع
المقدمه التي قدمتموها اخي عبد القادر
والتي تحدثت وك ان الوثيقه مقدمه للمرشحين
وكان
الوثيقه تطرح على المرشحين وبالتالي
احتمال ان ان تقبل القوى السياسيه الوطنيه
الثوريه التي قامت بالثوره المصريه باي من
المرشحين شريطه ان يتم تقدم في مثل هذه
الاتفاقيات معه انا لا اتصور ان هذا هو
المطروح في الحاله السياسيه المصريه ولا
في الحاله الشعبيه المصريه بمعنى ان دكتور
محمد دكتور محمد
نعم دكتور محمد الوثيقه قدمت للمرشحين وتم
اعلام ذلك ساعطيك المجال واعطيت لقدمت
للمرشحين وقدمت لهما بشكل مباشر وبشكل
علني على ان مضمونها كما قيل في التقرير
ايضا بانه موجه بشكل مباشر يعني بشكل راسي
الى محمد مرسي اكثر منه الى احمد
شفيق يعني اذا كان مفترضا ان تقدم مثل هذه
الوثيقه او يمكن ان تصدر تعهدات من السيد
احمد شفيق الذي ينزل غدا الى قلب ميدان
التحرير الحركات الثوريه والقوى الوطنيه
والسياسيه للتاكيد على ان استمرار احمد
شفيق في الحلبه الانتخابيه رغم ان قانونا
قد صدر لمنعه من الدخول اليها ورغم ان
قبول اللجنه العليا للانتخابات باستمرار
في العمليه الانتخابيه دون ان يصدر من
المحكمه الدستوريه العليا قرارا بالغاء او
الطعن او الرفض لقانون اصدره البرلمان
بعزله ثم الظواهر التي صاحبت تقدم احمد
شفيق الى ووصوله الى جوله الاعاده والتي
يدرك الشعب
الم عامل الوقت عامل الوقت فيما يتعلق
بتحديد نقطه النقاش وانا قد سالتك عن
موقفكم قلت كلاما جميلا في البدايه عن
مساله العهد الوطني ولكن ماذا عن مضمون
الوثيقه تقبلونها ترفضون ما هي ملاحظاتكم
عليها او على بعض بنودها
اؤكد ان مطلوب من القوى الوطنيه كما قدمت
هذه المبادرات وهذا صحيح لكن هي ليست
مبادره
تقدم لقوى وطنيه تقف على الحياد بين
مرشحين لكن بين مرشح يريد ان يعيد انتاج
النظام الماضي بكامل انتسابه له وافتخاره
ب بمثله الاعلى في حسني مبارك وباعا
انتاجه
لمنظومه القمع والقهر والفقر والمرض
والتزوير والحصار والتضييق الذي عاشها
الشعب المصري لمده 30 سنه وبالتالي ليست
القضيه ان يعترف او يقبل او يوافق احمد
شفيق على هذه الوثيقه او يرفض فهذا خارج
المساله المطروحه تماما لكن اقدر ان من
واجب الحريه والعداله وواجب الدكتور محمد
مرسي الان ان يجيب على مدى استعداد
الاخوان المسلمين ومدى استعداده هو شخصيا
لمشروع شراكه وطنيه يتحمل هو فييه اداره
مشهد المشروع الوطني بكافه تنوعه وكافه
تياراته سواء من خلال مؤسسه رئاسه يشارك
فيها نواب ينتمون لغير الحريه والعداله او
مستشارين ومساعدين كذلك يمثلون كافه طوائف
المجتمع المصري او من خلال حكومه ائتلافيه
ق ليس بالضروره ان ي احد من الحريه هذا من
باب من باب التمني ام من باب النقاش
الدائر الان وسط حزب الحريه والعداله
والمطروح بشكل جدي هذ الايا في التعاون مع
هذه
الوثيقه الدكتور محمد مرسي اول امس في
مؤتمره الصحفي وامس في حواره التلفزيونيه
اكد على المحاور الثلاثه الاولى انه يتحدث
عن مؤسسه رئاسه وليس عن رئيس فرد سواء
ينتمي او لا ينتمي رغم انه اكد انه في
اليوم التالي لاعلان نتيجه الانتخابات
سيقدم استقالته من الحريه والعداله ومن اي
موقع ينتمي اليه داخل الاخوان المسلمين
ليكون رئيسا لكل مصريين وليس محسوبا على
فصيل او حزب او جماعه الامر الثاني انه
تحدث عن شراكه في الحكومه الائتلافيه
الموسعه التي تتشكل من كافه التيارات
الوطنيه وقال انه ليس بالضروره ان يرقصها
احد من محسوبا على الحريه وال
كلكتور
محمد معروف على كل حال وقد ذكره في مؤتمر
الصحفي وكننا نتمنى ان نعرف الى اين وصلت
الى اين وصلت الامور من نقاشات داخل حزب
الحريه وال يتعلق بب الثقه ساعود لك ولكن
فقط اعطي المجال ضيفي ايضا من القاهره عمر
عز ساعود لك اعدك ساعود لك فقط حتى نسمع
ايضا موقف حركه 6 ابريل من الوثيقه عن
بنودها في حال تعاطي اي طرف معها بشكل
ايجابي ماذا عن تصرف وتصور 6 ابريل في
مساله التعاطي من الطرفين سواء احمد شفيق
او بالنسبه لمحمد مرسي وانتم قد بينتم
بانكم لن تكونوا مع احمد شفيق فيق
وبالتالي ماذا عن موقفكم في حاله تعاطي
ايجابيا مع هذه الوثيقه من الطرف الثاني
اه يعني لازم انا برحب الاول بالدكتور
محمد البلتاجي وبرحب بحضرتك لازم يكون
واضح قدام الناس كلها ان الوثيقه دي مش
موجهه لاحمد شفيق نهائي الوثيقه موجهه
للدكتور محمد مرسي لانه لا يكفي ليدعم
لتدعم القوى الثوريه الدكتور محمد مرسي
وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين في وجودهم في
سباق
الرئاسه مجرد وجود شفيق ا احنا احنا لسه
ما اعلنا دعمنا لدكتور محمد مرسي او عدم
دعمنا يعني احنا الموقف متارجح ما بين
المشاركه في الانتخابات او مقاطعه
الانتخابات ت نهائيا ده توقف على مدى
تفاعل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين متمثله الان
في الدكتور محمد مرسي في مدى قبوله للشروط
احنا مش محتاجين وعود محتاجين يبقى ف
طاوله للتفاوض مع القوى السياسيه وعلى
اساس تفاعل القوى السياسيه مع الدكتور
محمد مرسي وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين سنتخذ
موقفنا يا اما بدعم الدكتور محمد مرسي
والعمل من اجل ان يصل لكرسي الرئاسه او
نقف موقف حياد ما بين المرشحين ون نقاطع
الانتخابات نهائيا طيب دكتور محمد
البلتاجي تقدمون انفسكم بانكم قوه ثوريه
ومن تقدم بهذه المقترحات ايضا تقدم نفس ها
بانها قوى ثوريه وتهدف الى تطبيق اهداف
الثوره بكل جراه ما هي محاذير فيما يتعلق
بما جاء في هذه الوثيقه من بنود او بعض
بنودها يعني اؤكد انه لا توجد ايه محاذير
نحن نتحدث عن ضروره ان تتتر وتتحول الوعود
التي والمبادئ التي تحدث عنها الدكتور
محمد مرسي واخذها على نفسه التزاما بان
تتحول كما ما قلت مؤسسه الرئاسه الى مؤسسه
فيها نواب ومساعدين ومستشارين من تيارات
اخرى وان تتشكل الحكومه القادمه من كافه
التيارات الوطنيه و ان نشكل هيئه
التاسيسيه لوضع الدستور الجديد خلال
الايام القليله القادمه بما يعبر عن توافق
وطني واسع يؤكد هذا كله في مجمله الشراكه
الوطنيه للقوى الثوريه ا تشير الى ان
المحسوب على الثوره من او ذاك او هؤلاء او
اولئك القضيه نحن الشعب المصري يدرك جيدا
كيف كانت كل هذه التيارات الاسلاميه
والليبراليه واليسار والقوميه جنبا الى
جنب في نضال عبر عشرات السنين قبل الثوره
ثم معا ضد النظام السابق الذي يمثله الان
احمد شفيق وتقف من ورائه الدوله العميقه
بكل اجهزتها اجهزه المعلومات واجهزه الامن
والاجهزه التنيه اذرني اعذرني ا اذ كنت
اقاطعك كثيرا ولكن دائما النقطه الجوهريه
تقول كلاما جميلا ولكن الان الشارع المصري
الهيئه الناخب الان في مصر في تحديد
وجهتها في الجوله القادمه تريد ان تسمع
اجابات على اسئله مباشره فيما يتعلق
بتحديد الاستقطابات القادمه بالنسبه
للاسماء الموجوده او ما يتعلق بهذه النقاط
الاساسيه التي وردت في الوثيقه ماذا عن
اجابات مباشره على هذه النقاط تقبلون بهذه
الوثيقه تستقطب شرائح اخرى من الشارع
المصري لا تقبلون بها لديكم محاذير ند ان
نفهم
اتفق تماما مع ما قاله الان اخي الاستاذ
عمرو عز وهو يتحدث عن ضروره ان تتحول هذه
المطالب التي تطالب بها القوى الوطنيه
تحديدا الدكتور محمد مرسي وليست تعرضها
على الطرفين لان لا يمكن الحديث عن الحياد
بين الطرفين او المساواه بين الطرفين لكن
هم يتحدثون وهذا حقهم وهذا واجب الاخوان
المسلمين وواجب الدكتور محمد مرسي ان يجيب
خلال الايام القليله القادمه على مائده
مفاوضات تفصيليه تتحدث عن كيف تتحول
الاجراءات التي او الوعود التي قطعها على
نفسه الى اشخاص وهيئات
وقوى تتشارك سويا سواء في مؤسسه الرئاسه
او في الهيئه التاسيسيه للدستور او في
الحكومه التي سيشكلها رئيس الجمهوريه
القادم ويعني بالتالي هذا هو المطلوب ان
يجيب عليه الان الدكتور محمد مرسي من خلال
لقاءات مباشره لكن هذا هذا الواجب على
الجميع السعي لهذه الشراكه الوطنيه هو
واجب الجميع اما حين ان يخرج البعض يتحدث
الان عن انه يقف على الحياد او عن انه
يمكن ان يذهب الى شفيق اذا اعطاه من
الوعود ما لم يعطيه محمد مرسي او ان
يتحدث البعض عن يعني احتمال ان عن
المساواه بين الفريقين فاظن ان هذه ليست
الحاله المطروحه في الساحه من حق القوى
الوطنيه ان تشترط وتطمئن على شراكه وطنيه
في الايام الايام القادمه بعد الانتخابات
يكون فيها الاخوان المسلمون جزء من حركه
وطنيه واسعه سنواصل دتور محمد الجزء
الث سنواصل هذا الموضوع تحديدا مساله
الاستقطابات مساله الاستعداد ذات ومدى
واقعيه ما جاء في هاتين الوثيقتين وايضا
مساله الاستقطابات في جلب اصوات الناخبين
والكتل السياسيه والاسماء التي سقطت في
الجوله الاولى ومن معها في الجوله الثانيه
من الانتخابات الرئاسيه المصريه بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي
تتناول مؤشرات تحالفات مرحله الاعاده في
انتخابات الرئاسه المصريه وارحب واجدد
الترحيب بضيفي من القاهره الدكتور محمد
البلتاجي وكذلك عمر عز عن حركه 6 ابريل
عمر عندما تقول بان ان هذه الوثيقه موجهه
فقط للدكتور محمد مرسي وانتم كنتم تهدد
بال المقاطعه المقاطعه وتوجيه الرساله فقط
لطرف واحد الا يضعف من ثقل هذه المطالبه
في
مساله اجبارها او جعلها سبيل واحد لدى طرف
واحد وبالتالي يثقل من وزنها كوسيله
ضغط يعني نحن لا نعترف بوجود احمد شفيق
قانونا احمد شفيق المفروض ما كانش موجود
اصلا في الانتخابات وشرعيته القانونيه
منقوصه احمد شفيق هو احد رموز النظام
السابق اللي عزل قانون العزل ولم ياخذ
بقانون العزل اللجنه العليا للانتخابات
المشرفه على انتخابات الرئاسه اعتقد ان هو
غير موجود في حساباتنا نهائي ولكن احنا
بنسعى لشراكات بتسعى لشراكات حقيقيه مع
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين الشراكه دي مشروطه
بان بنود هذه الاتفاقيه
او المبادرات تتحول ل عقد التزام وليست
مجرد وعود من الدكتور محمد مرسي الشارع
محتاج ان هو يطمن وانصار القوه السياسيه
او القوه الثوريه محتاجين ان هم يطمنوا
هناك علامات استفهام كثيره من بعد وجود
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين كاغ لبيه داخل
البرلمان في ادائها البرلماني داخل
البرلمان على الاقل قانون العزل السياسي
اللي طلع متاخر جدا وبعض الاشياء المريبه
اللي حصلت من ت تشكيل جما الاسيه
للدستور بغض النظر عن المواقف السياسيه
وهي محترمه تجاه اي طرف من الطرفين ولكن
هناك حسابات انتخابيه المقاطعه في حال عدم
الاستجابه لمطالبهم حسابيا معناه بان فريق
ما قد تكون لا تعترفون به انتم ربما قد
سيكسب نظر لهذه المقاطعه وبالتالي ماذا عن
هذه
الحسابات
نحن لا نخشى الرئيس القادم الشعب المصري
والقوى الثوريه ستتعامل مع الرئيس القادم
ايا كان ستقوم اذا انحرف عن الطريق لن
نسمح لوجود دوله بوليسيه مره اخرى لن نسمح
بتجاوزات ضد القانون وتجاوزات ضد القوى
السياسيه
والابتعاد مره اخرى عن الحريات التي
اكتسبناها عن طريق الثوره ايا كان الرئيس
القادم سنتعامل معه ايا كان شكله لو لو
اصبح الرئيس القادم احمد شفيق اعتقد ان
احنا سنصور عليه ونعيد بناء النظام من اول
جديد ا لو كان الدكتور محمد مرسي في حاله
وجود شراكه حقيقيه تمت تم الاتفاق عليها
وتم تنفيذها فيما بعد وجوده كرئيس اعتقد
ان الامور هتبقى هادئه ولكن اذا جاء
الدكتور حتى الدكتور محمد مرسي واستئثار
الاخوان المسلمين بالحكم في مصر س سنقاوم
هذا الاستئثار ولن نترك مره اخرى الحاكم
في مصر بان يكون فرعون ايا كان اسمه او
ايا كان الجماعه التي او القوه السياسيه
التي ينتمي ليها احنا مش خايفين من الرئيس
القادم احنا نحتاج ان الدنيا محتاجين ان
الدنيا تهدا في مصر ونبتدي بناء الدوله
المصريه كما يجب ان يكون ده يحتاج مننا
تطمينات لبقى لنبقى في الموضوع الاني الان
قبل مساله الحسم في الانتخابات القادمه
ايا كان الرئيس كما ذكرت هنا اتوجه بسؤال
الدكتور محمد البلتاجي ايضا في ظل العمليه
الحسابيه التي نت
عن الجوله الاولى في الانتخابات التي افضت
الى الاسمين محمد مرسي واحمد شفيق من
خلالكم انتم ماذا عن تحرك مع بقيه الاسماء
عن حمدين صباحي ومن يمثل مع الدكتور عبد
النعم فتوح ومن يمثل ما الذي قمتم به حتى
الان من خطوات من اجل صناعه ارقام جديده
متوقعه تكون نتيجه للانتخابات
القادمه دعني اولا اخي عبد القادر ان يعني
اعبر عن سعادتي وانا استمع الى جيل ثوره
25 يناير يعني من عمرو عز وامثاله وهم
يؤكدون ان هذا الجيل لن يقبل لا لامتدادات
النظام السابق ان تعيد انتاج نفسها مره
ثانيه ولا حتى للدكتور محمد مرسي او غيره
ان يخرج عن اطار مشروع وطني يحقق مطالب
هذا الجيل وهذا الشعب بكل مفرداته من حريه
وديمقراطيه وكرامه وعد اجتماعيه
شراكه حقيقيه تيار واحد فقط دكتور محمد
نعم نعم وانا اقدر
هذه وقلت ان هذه المخاوف هي مخاوف مشروعه
ومن حق القوه الوطنيه ان تضعها على طاوله
التفاوض المباشر وانا ناديت اول امس
تحديدا يعني المفاتيح الرئيسيه في الحركه
الوطنيه اليوم باعتبار النتائج الانتخابيه
وهم الدكتور عبد المنعم ابو الفتوح
والاستاذ حمدين صباحي وغيرهم من المرشحين
الذين خاضوا تلك التجربه محسوبين على
الحركه الوطنيه وليس على النظام السابق ان
يدخلوا مباشره في مائده تفاوض محدده
المعالم تحيل ما وعد به الدكتور محمد مرسي
من وعود ومن التزامات في اطار عام الى
تفاصيل محدده لكن ولا زال النداء للاستاذ
حمدين صباحي على وجه الخصوص الا يبتعد عن
هذه الشراكه الوطنيه وان لا يقف موقف
الحياد وانا يساوي بين امتدادات النظام
السابق وبين شركاء وطنيين قد يكون قد
اختلف معهم او تنافس معهم في بعض المواقع
لكن نريد من الجميع الان الاصطفاف الوطني
التي تدعو له وف الوطني دكتور محمد
الاصطفاف الوطني ما الذي ما الذي كان
سيخسر الدكتور محمد مرسي وبالتالي حزب
الحريه والعداله واجاب سريعا على هاتين
الوثيقتين الاتفاق الوطني او العهد الوطني
بالايجاب ما تم ذكره في وثيقه العهد
الوطني من حديث عن الدوله المدنيه
الديمقراطيه القائمه على احترام حقوق
الانسان والحريات العامه وتداول السلطه
وا الشراكه الوطنيه هو محل اتفاق لم نختبر
فيه من قبل كما اختبر نظام سابق وقصرنا في
ذلك الحديث عن الشراكه في مؤسسه الرئاسه
او مؤسسه الحكومه هو ما يجب ان يتحول
الى اشخاص باعينهم من خلال حديث مباشر
يشارك فيه الان وانا اعيد التذكره واعيد
ان داء للاخوين الكريمين الدكتور عبم فوح
والاستاذ حمدين صباحي وغيرهم من الاخوه
الكرام الذين شاركوا في سباق الانتخابات
الرئاسيه للجلوس المباشر وهذا تم توجيه
هذه الدعوه من قبل من قبل الدكتور محمد
مرسي ونحن نؤكد عليها لكيف نشكل مؤسسه
رئاسه يشارك فيها الى جانب الدكتور محمد
مرسي الذي اعلن انه ليس فقط يوافق بل هو
يحتاج الى من يقف الى جواره من نواب
يتحملون مسؤوليتهم وفق اختصاصات محدده في
مؤسسه
ولكنه الى الان لم يقبل او يرفض ما جاء في
هذه الوثيقه اتوجه بسؤالي الى عمر عز في
المقابل لو قال الدكتور محمد مرسي نعم
لهذه
الوثيقه ما الذي سيضمن له بالنسبه ما
يتعلق بعمليه استقطاب الاصوات وبالتالي
ترجيح الكفه هل تضمن له
ذلك يعني انا اعتقد ان في حاله قبول
الدكتور محمد مرسي لهذه الوثيقه وانا شايف
ان الوثيقه دي ما تتخدش عن طريق الاعلام
ده لازم يبقى فيه طاوله للمفاوضات على كل
الشروط اللي موجوده فيها وبعد كده هيبقى
في حلول وسط ما بين رؤيه الدكتور محمد
مرسي والشركاء في الوطن الشركاء السياسيين
اعتقد ان الشارع هيطمن لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وستبتعد فكره استئثار بالحكم عن
الشارع والقوى الثوريه ستنطلق هي وانصارها
لدعم الدكتور محمد مرسي بشكل كبير في ا و
في الشارع وتدعو كل من يدعو لمقاطعه
الانتخابات الذي اعتقد انه سيؤثر باللب
على موقف الدكتور محمد مرسي وانا لا اتمنى
ذلك سيدعو كل هؤلاء الذين يدعوا للمقاطعه
لعوده مره اخرى للاصطفاف الوطني وترجيح
كافه الدكتور محمد مرسي والعمل حتى يكون
الدكتور محمد مرسي في اشكرك عمرو عز عضو
حركه 6 ابريل الجبهه الديمقراطيه كما اشكر
ضيفي من القاهره الدكتور محمد البلتاجي
عضو مجلس والقياده في حزب الحريه والعداله
بذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله